where are you looking for these
interview subjects now where do you post
things is it on Craigslist or it's
always to look for interview subjects
for a documentary it's always going to
be a completely new and different thing
every time for example no I mean the
most the biggest and the best thing you
could do is just hire someone who does
it for like reality show a producer or
associate producer who does it for a
reality show which I do
and on the kind of the lower budget
level obviously they get they make much
more money than they make per say on my
documentaries and the reason I'm telling
you guys this is if you're doing it for
film courage you can sort of get get a
person of this level to work on your
documentary the reason that they worked
on my documentaries is because they're
probably more I wouldn't say more
interesting because this sounds very
narcissistic but you know they're more
hefty I guess the new your average
reality show so they you know they enjoy
looking for subject matters like I have
one documentary where shooting is about
people who wanted to be they had a dream
of something that he wanted in their 20s
to be an artist to be a writer
and now that they're like 70 or 80 they
you know they never accomplished that
they went to another field so it's like
you know it's hefty stuff as opposed to
you know we're gonna put people on a
beach and see you can't an the best or
something you know yeah and then
obviously it's still when you're getting
trying to get interviewees for
documentaries it's still that covers
some of it but you still kind of have to
have a game plan for how you do that yet
for our Daltrey one and you know it's
all kinds of stuff it's it's it was a
hiring a few people who were reality
producers and then it was finding people
through just ran
raining I think I found people through
going to parties events who were just
visiting for like two weeks hey I'm
visiting for two weeks you know there's
a girl from Spain I interviewed who was
like just here for two weeks she's on
vacation and oh I would really like to
interview you for the documentary fent
friends of friends friends of family
obviously a lot of documentaries shoots
or are a lot of documentaries are from
people who know the friend of a family
or friend of a friend who's the
documentary subjects that's very common
so those are the general things you know
it's always something new every single
time to try to find interview subjects
it's not a very easy thing to do per se
either but you get it done
there's people who specially who are
really good at it too and hopefully you
work with those people
you